. Let's go next to Tyler in Vancouver,
our friendly neighbors to the north.
Do you hear me? Yes, I can. Tyler, can you
hear me? Yes, I can. Tyler, I'm doing well.
Excellent. I have a question. I'm sure you've
covered this before, but it seems from afar that
the Republican Party and its supporters have laid
claim to the idea of American patriotism in the
name of their cause and no one else's. I don't
know if it's become a big recruiting tool for
American right, but feels like it's everyone who's
not with them. Is an American fascist, right?
Yeah. No, this is this is not new. I mean,
it probably goes back many decades. But
as far as I've been covering politics during the
George W. Bush era, if you didn't support the
war in Iraq, you weren't really a patriot.
That became a big, big talking point then.
Yeah, and so my question is how how has
it become that the right has laid claim
to patriotism and how can the what can
the left do to reclaim that from them?
Yet George Lakoff has written about this quite a
bit. The right has not only succeeded on taking
patriotism, they've succeeded on framing
and branding on a bunch of different issues.
You know, pro-life sounds great. And they
succeeded on that. Tax relief is another
one that George Lakoff. Wow, that's a relief.
You're removing the burden of taxation of this
is not unique to patriotism.
And I don't have any
unique ideas on it other than to say I would look
at Lakoff on this and some of his suggestions. And
Democrats just aren't very good at this. I mean,
listen, if it were me, I would say patriotism
should be about look at how well we take care
of everybody from the standpoint of health care.
Look at how well-designed our cities are to
have great public transit and green spaces and
connection between richer and poorer. You know,
none of these things are true now, but like those
would be the types of things for me that seem
like the ones I would want to be patriotic about
rather than like we have the most weapons or
we have the most guns or whatever. I think it
needs to be a complete paradigm shift on framing.
I completely agree and just one more note on that,
yeah, that how how do I try to figure
out the best way to kind of access is?
If the left's ideas are somehow seen as
anti-American, you know, like repealing or
the Second Amendment, but no, having stronger
gun security stuff, how can we fight against
that being anti American value when it's just
not you know, it's better for the country.
It's really just a it's unfortunately
merely a propaganda and rhetorical
war at this point. So you just have to be
better at rhetoric that that's that simple.
The kind of shame that could
policies come to the David Pakman,
there you go. I agree with you. I agree with
you. I appreciate the call. There's so much.
Tyler from Vancouver, thank you so much
for the call. Very much. Appreciate it.